du cinéma au documentaire je reçois
présent pour le plateau du 7-8 week end
guillaume massart bonsoy adrien
mitterrand également réalisateur du
documentaire physio police 4 qui sera
diffusée sur télé filer une première
fois le 7 mai à 21h physio police c'est
ce domaine créé dans l'île de plaques
était dans le creux de la seine entre
triel mais dans villennes sur seine dans
les yvelines domaine créé en 1928 par
deux frères médecin gaston et andrée
d'urville particularité la vie en
harmonie avec la nature le développement
du corps par les exercices sportifs ça
c'est pour la phrase le ver sont longues
plus court c'était un domaine naturiste
c'est ça qui vous a passionné
qu'est ce qui vous a lancé dans cette
affaire dans cette aventure en fait
alors c'est adrian qui s'est retrouvé
sur cette île le premier non pas pour
faire du naturisme et part en dispersant
matière non 119 symbolique non plus il
est en repérage pour une fiction et
il ya découvert sept îles en cherchant
des lieux de tournage dans 78 et
peut-être que tu peux raconter ta
découverte de cette île oui disons que
c'est quand même un endroit qui est très
impressionnant visuellement et c'est
vrai que je suis passé de l'idée de ces
pas une fiction qu'il faut faire là bas
c'est tout simplement un documentaire
parce qu'il suffit déjà de le filmer
dans le réel pour que ce soit très
impressionnant on a quand même gardé un
peu cette histoire de fiction puisque le
film est un mélange entre un
documentaire et une fiction
effectivement les téléspectateurs auront
l'occasion de le découvrir on va essayer
de pas trop tout dévoiler sa dure une
petite heure mais on va quand même
évoqué le l'histoire justement
l'histoire c'est quoi ce sont les
réalisateurs qui se met un petit peu en
scène et qui découvre une île où
l'atmosphère encore aujourd'hui même si
ce n'est plus un domaine naturiste est
encore particulière tout à fait en fait
faut savoir que donc nous on est on est
présent comme protagoniste donc dans nos
propres rôles d'une certaine façon
puisqu'on nous entend
derrière les réglages de la caméra on
entend nos questions et c'est donc oui
c'est le point de vue du film nous
inclus dans la narration global après
c'est quand une façon d'explorer façon
documentaire le lieu donc on interroge
les résidents pour savoir comment il
s'approprie lille parce qu'effectivement
il ya encore des résidents qui sont là
bientôt 100 ans après l'ouverture du
site certains sont là depuis d'ailleurs
très très longtemps je pense à cette
dame qui était arrivé vers 1939 qui
explique que c'était mieux avant c'est
une rencontre particulière aussi oui bah
c'était la doyenne de lille donc quand
on l'a rencontré on savait qu'elle
aurait à des histoires à nous raconter à
n'en plus finir alors on a quelques unes
et on l'a beaucoup et d'ailleurs il
était impossible de l'arrêter et on la
laissait parler parler parler sa parole
rebondissait dans tous les sens créer
des nouvelles histoires qui reprenait
sur d'autres comme des boutures et on
s'est dit c'est un peu c'est la première
personne avec qui on a fait une longue
interview comme ça et c'est elle qui
nous allons c'est dans cette idée que
chacun aurait une histoire à raconter
sur 7 il cite à ce que cette histoire
soit peut-être on sait jamais fantasmé
déformé un peu grossi et on a gardé ce
principe si bien que c'est un
documentaire certes mais dans lequel on
laisse toujours la possibilité que tout
ça soit un peu fictionnel un peu faux
seins de son roman faire aussi un qui
règne tout autour est ce que justement
cette atmosphère qui règne dans ce
documentaire c'est ce que vous avez
ressenti vous sur place exactement en
fait c'est assez étrange
on a essayé de retranscrire vraiment au
montage ce qu'on a ressenti sur place
parce que déjà ça c'était une expérience
assez extraordinaire parce que ces
ruines déjà de l'ancien centre de
thalassothérapie quai à côté et vraiment
c'est incroyable comme lieu donc on a
essayé de ressentir ça et c'est pour ça
qu'on a laissé la place à l'imaginaire
dans les interviews par exemple et des
enfants aussi qu'on a interviewé qui
nous racontent un peu ce qu'ils
s'imaginent avoir vu dans les ruines
c'était important pour restituer
l'ambiance parce qu'effectivement le
domaine a beaucoup changé aujourd'hui
c'est un lieu où réside encore des gens
il ya certaines ruines vous les avez
mentionné qu'ils sont toujours là ce qui
fait que cohabitent encore un petit peu
de vie et puis les fantômes du passé
aussi sur cette île lille a changé elle
était un refuge aussi pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale les résidents ont
ensuite repris une tradition de
rencontre un peu plus festive dans quel
état d'esprit sont les gens aujourd'hui
qu'ils résident vivre dans le passé sont
tournés vers l'avenir qui réside sur
cette île aujourd'hui c'est des gens qui
viennent surtout passer un week end
c'est vraiment devenu une île où les
gens viennent se détendre viennent
prendre leur petit leur zèle à la
campagne lorsque son bébé galons encore
qu'il soit là c'est encore des bungalows
et les gens viennent oui pour se mettre
au vert quoi vraiment pour se mettre au
vert est ce qu'on nous raconte un peu
sur l'île c'est que depuis que il ya le
coup l'électricité partout il ya l'eau
courante etc c'est peut-être devenu un
peu moins convivial que ça pouvait
l'être au moment où un voilà n'y avait
pas la télévision notamment la révision
était pas arrivé jusque là si bien que
les gens se retrouvaient le soir
discuter entre eux voilà ça me faisait
vraiment il y avait une vie collective
et la maintenance et plus des pavillons
du week end qui ont été rachetés par des
versets c'est un peu embourgeoisé quoi
si on veut regarder la bande-annonce
pour voir un petit peu l'idée de
l'atmosphère qui règne sur place et puis
on va poursuivre la discussion ensuite
oh là
là pour
aborder la course au large
si ma tempe droite
josé la terre au bout de la
nuit on a manqué je saurai jean audouze
il me rend très fier mais on a manqué
la ville aux lamas
tout
bientôt
il avoue la maman
le tout
et là vous aux nazis
ma vie
la gauche ne pas
rater
on
l'a aperçu avec cette bande-annonce vous
faites en permanence ce parallèle et
c'est de plus en plus fort au fur à
mesure du documentaire entre ce site on
ne peut pas détruire qui est protégé
csrd l'huile en fait d'une ancienne
thalasso énorme piscine c'était assez
gigantesque ce gigantesque et à côté la
vie qui continue à courir avec aussi des
enfants même si on ne les voit pas et
vous avez privilégié les natures mortes
sur les compositions tant d'années ce
qui renforce un peu ce côté un peu un
peu paradoxal c'est que c'est comment
cette découverte du lieu que vous avez
fait que je pense je pense à ce lieu
pour lequel qu'on ne peut pas raser et
encore des archives qui traîne à même le
sol on peut consulter enfin pour ceux
qui enjambe les barrières mais c'est une
des choses qui nous a le plus marqué
c'est que c'est vrai qu'on voit les
strates de l'histoire qui sont encore
dessus puisque ça fait ça fait des
dizaines et des dizaines d'années que
des choses s'accumulent ou disparaissent
mais globalement il ya encore des
tapisseries on n'arrive pas à savoir si
elles sont des années 70 des années 50
tout est mélangé savez qu'il ya encore
un un espèce de cadavres de piano enfin
donc il suffit de regarder autour et
encore une fois c'est surtout
l'imaginaire de l'histoire du lieu qui
apparaît quand on regarde ce qui reste
dans les bâtiments il n'y a pas
d'informations on donne pas dans le film
d'informations précises dont ils sont l
année c'est pas ces satanés s'est passé
ça chacun longueur de citations des
choses aussi des vagues à travers les
témoignages chacun livre un petit peu se
sont ressentis sur la vie qu'il a pu
mener ici et ce qu'il a entendu aussi
sur ce lieu aujourd'hui désertés des
allemands aux signes ont résidé c'est ce
qu'on nous raconte c'est ce qu'un des
témoins racontent agilité - parce que
ouais ça peut être bien de dire ça comme
ça c'est des témoignages
c'est des choses qui sont dites c'est de
la tradition orale quoi donc c'est parce
parler les gens aucun moment où on est
allé vérifier l'ensemble des faits
exactement on laisse on laisse les
choses comme ça alors on sait que après
que que d'oeuvre nous a raconté cette
histoire avec éventuellement la présence
d'aliments sur l'île pendant pendant
l'occupation
d'autres résidents nous ont dit on n'a
jamais entendu parler de ça c'est
étrange etc et on n'a jamais pu avoir le
fin mot est donc on s'est dit
il faut que notre film soit nourri
d'autres récits qui puisse être
sujet à caution et que du coup lorsqu'on
arrive sur ce récit là on sache pas si
c'est du lard ou du cochon mais que quoi
qu'il en soit
les vocations permet en tout cas de
réfléchir à lille différemment de
l'es7 il parle d'elle-même de plein de
choses raconte des histoires en
permanence et parfois elle sonnerait
parfois elles sont fausses on sera
jamais vraiment et vous mentionniez cet
hôtel dans lequel on est entré qu'un
hôtel complètement à l'abandon mais où
tous les registres sont par terre seront
réparés par comme sa répartie sur le sol
et il suffit de ramasser n'importe quel
registre pour que soudain on soit dans
une fiction on lit madame joly est
arrivée à telle heure elle a dépensé
tant d'argent elle a mangé ça me dit ça
y est les dentelles chambre et on
ramasse plein de choses comme ça au
hasard et il suffit de lire toutes ses
phrases des unes après les autres pour
que investissent créent sous nos yeux
quoi tout seul et puis une dernière
question c'est une phrase de vous
répondre me répondre qu'il s'agisse de
fiction comme de documentaires il ya
toujours du mensonge il ya montage il ya
choix de cadres de durée de motifs
est-ce que vous avez menti sur ce film
oui forcément puisqu'on a filmé on a
très clairement voilà le fait de filmer
c'est mentir mon essayer de le faire de
façon le plus honnête possible
et ce sera à découvrir sur l'antenne de
téléfilms mardi 7 mai 21h rediffusion
samedi 11 dimanche 12 à 15 heures merci
à vous d'être venu nous présenter cette
réalisation